Okay,
let's,
let's quickly study how to compete surface
marbles because we are going to need
that.
If you remember the diagrams,
we always had the surface from a diffuse
specular and the ambient shading.
And just a quick remark,
in the previous lecture we have talked
about diffuse inspecting your shading and
also MBN.
But these are perhaps the most important
was what does simplify the rds.
The idea falls and you
can see them everywhere.
So when you are on public transport you
can think about what objects could be,
what exact case I'm objects or
like a mixture of these BRDF moms.
It is possible that I have a diffuse
object with a glossy or respect,
a little coating on top of it.
And you can move your head around like I
told you before and and see how the new
cost,
the object changes.
So a lot of beauty to Margo app and you
will be able to also understand that for
instance,
if you watch someone performing stand
up comedy is that are usually uh,
a law of guys seem to Morris things and
they all always we'd wear makeup and the
makeup artist tells them that, yes, you
need to wear makeup. And the artist says,
I'm a manly guy, I don't want to wear
makeup. And they say, well, I don't care.
You have to because otherwise
you are sparkly. Okay.
And this means that they start sweating
and if they start sweating that the skin
is going to get a bit
already and then specular,
it's more specular.
Sweet means that if I turned my head
around it go look a bit different.
So there's going to be specular
highlights and if you use makeup dandies
specular highlights disappear and the
whole face is going to be almost perfectly
diffused. Therefore it doesn't
distract your audience.
So trust parties everywhere.
So if you ever wear makeup,
then think about this
specular reflections.
Okay? But I digress. So surface normals.
I haven't even visited equation F of x,
y zero I would like to know
the normals of the surface,
how to construct a normal well [inaudible]
is given by the 20th of the function.
And just a quick,
yeah,
just a quick reminder to
Craig went off the function.
This is a three d function of x,
Y,
Z and the gradient when every quarter
that gives you the derivative of the
function with respect to a given quarter.
Okay,
let's see an example.
Imagine Elliptic parable out.
You don't have to imagine that
because there's going to be an image,
so this is x squared
over a squared and so on.
I'm not going to read formula and this
is how it looks like and if I would like
to put together something like this,
then I have to know that a and B are the
curvatures of this thing in different
different dimensions and therefore
these values are scalar values.
Well,
let's compute the surface normal of
this elliptic paraboloid but this would
include differentiating the whole equation
for the first coordinate with respect
to x. So let's differentiate
this with respect to x,
but x squared is going to be two x and
eight squared is going to remain there
because it's a Schema.
Multiply it.
Why does it depend on x?
It doesn't depend on the next effort.
False off z.
It doesn't depend on x.
Therefore the first quarter
will be two x over a squared.
What about the second term?
The second term because the function
differentiated with respect to why. Okay.
Does x dependent, why no, it's turn
is going to be zero. What about this?
Why is crime is going to be too wide over
[inaudible]? Z doesn't depend on why.
Therefore this is going
to be the second term.
What about the third time I differentiate
is function with respect to z. Z,
does it depend on x?
Someone let me know.
I mean correct. It doesn't depend
on him. Does it depend on why?
Well, what's going to be
the type of this expression?
It's going to be minus a bit louder.
It's going to be minus
one. Okay. Let's see. Okay,
we got this so we can cause track the
social snowman off an elliptic parabolic.
Excellent.
So when we do this intersection
routine in ray tracing,
I have a way,
and I would like to intersect this
against every single object that is in the
room.
The question is what is the
first object that the ray hits?
Which intersection am I interested in?
So
that may be men.
So if I lose summer,
I may intersect many different objects.
But if things are not translucent or
things aren't transparent that I'm only
going to see the first
intersection and that's it.
And the first should be the closest.
So this should be easy because we
are using parametric equations,
they depend on t and t is the distance.
So basically what we get as an output,
this is going to be a list of
t values that our interests,
I am intersecting these
objects at least of taste five,
10 miles to things like that.
What the question is,
which one do I choose out of this
list of teas? Simon, help me out.
Smiles.
I wasn't too t the smallest positive team.
Amy. So the negative ones
are not interested in like
I told you, long politics,
politics,
free zone.
And I wrote to be interested
in the smallest positive t.
There's those moments, true negative
teas we are not interested in.
We have discussed this and the
question is can we take t equals zero?
And I'm not telling this because I would
be an annoying mathematician only half
metal edition and Land Wunderkinder.
Okay,
so I'm asking this because I
would be annoyed with addition.
I'm asking this because this is going
to happen if you're right or a tracer.
So lots of people are it all something
is not working when I have no idea what
went wrong.
It is possible that t equals zero
and we need to handle this case.
So just a second,
raise your hand if you,
if you mow equals zero means intersection.
Okay,
excellent. I will have
some of my own destiny, so
okay. Yeah. Just a minute ago.
Okay. Yeah. Ask Her name. Okay,
so what's happening with the team to zero?
Sorry.
Yes,
exactly.
So if we have some amount
of bounces equals zero this
means that I am exactly on
the surface of the object
that I'm bouncing off of.
So if I intersect,
the guest is sphere and I bounced or a
bag the next after the next intersection
routine, I am almost guaranteed
to see machine precision matters.
But mathematically I'm guaranteed a CTO
or CEO because it's south intersection.
The raid comes to this direction,
bounces back from the table,
but it is for the top of the team where
there's going to be like a trivial
intersection which is from
the starting point of direct.
So we are not interested in
this so we are going to take
the smallest negative and non zero t.
So in cold we usually put there in epsilon
like a very small number and we say
that if it's the very least this lumber,
then I will take the intersection because
it's not self intersection anymore.
Okay. After we buy just
a smell, beauty break,
this is an image rendered with lux render,
our glorious renderer.
We are going to use this
later during the course. Okay.
And some more motivation will be
able to compute images like that.
Isn't this beautiful
random photo that's cheating?
Well,
if you're in the mood to a model,
like an extremely high Polycarp seizure,
yeah, people do that
too. And yeah, but it,
it gives you a really
realistic lighting off to seat.
You can, you can use this thing in a later
assignment to create beautiful images.
By the way, there's a course
gallery, make sure to take a look,
because from previous years
people have created some amazing,
amazing, uh, seeds. Raise your hand
if you have seen in this gallery.
Okay. From the people who are the
people who haven't seen, it's your hand.
If you are going to take a look at this
after every course. Okay, excellent.
You know, I didn't, I
didn't see your hand.
You have, you have an apple,
but you have to be serious.
There's some amazing things.
I wouldn't say some people should have
gone artists instead because this would
say something about their knowledge and
it's lack of place at all because these
terms are really smart guys,
but they have some amazing artistic
skills and I'm sure that there are some
artists inside,
some of you as well.